weirdly I was the homecoming king at my
school but you were the homecoming king
I know I you wait a hundred and ten
pounds yes that's right and you wore a
heavy woman's coat yes I like that you
made it a woman's coat which in fact it
probably was I probably was a
hand-me-down from an aunt or something
yeah but yeah I was well what happened
was there was a bunch of handsome
athletic gentlemen who were prospective
homecoming kings and I think through
some sort of electoral fluke like they
they split the vote among themselves and
then all of the freaks were like it's
our movement like we could get one of
ours it was like Nightmare Before
Christmas yeah yeah yeah yeah and so I I
became the homecoming they were like
coke boy well he will make him our king
so you became who this total fluke
homecoming king oddly enough we have a
picture of you from back then and
[Applause]
well that was prom that was like from
the program that they handed out at the
game and I remember they're like we're
gonna take this photo for the homecoming
program so just make sure you smile and
I was like I think I don't I'm not gonna
smile I want to make this face and they
were like smile you look crazy you know
and I thought it'd be funny so I just
insisted on making that face but I
didn't realize the extent to which I
look like kind of like the Fuhrer